joining me now he just finished the
debate New York gubernatorial candidate
Republican Congressman Lee zeldin
congressman
I mean I I know you know I know I'm
biased because I obviously want you to
win but you did wipe the floor with
hokel tonight she just does not have a
record she can defend
no I mean she was given many
opportunities but she kept trying to
change the subject and just wants to
talk Trump you ask her about crime Trump
you're asking her about corruption Trump
we're talking about her pay-to-play
corruption we're talking about people
who want to grow an economy they feel
like their safety is under attack they
they're hitting their Breaking Point
deciding whether or not to stay in New
York or head to some other state and
you're getting an opportunity to let
people know where you stand what your
record is what your positions are and
instead of utilizing that opportunity to
talk about what she stands for shoot the
fact that she's deflecting I would say
people are out there listening even if
they didn't even like Trump
they also care about safety they also
care about their wallets so she probably
lost support even from people who going
in were behind her and may not have even
voted for for president Trump I think
she bled out a lot of support tonight
and certainly I think very much and uh
fired up our people
I think
um over this next sound bite to your
point has to go to all the you know
independent-minded people and even
Democrats sort of more traditional
Democrats who still live in Manhattan
this is a revealing Exchange
first thing I'll do right after I'm
sworn in office is turning the Manhattan
district attorney Alvin Bragg to let him
know that he's being removed and it's
from day one that he was a district
attorney he said that he was not going
to enforce all different kinds of laws
across the board do you want to respond
I'd be happy to I'm not surprised
because in Lee zeldin's world you
overturn elections you don't agree with
but for someone who voted to overturn a
presidential election I'm not surprised
he just thinks whenever he wants to do
something he can just you know undo the
will of the people a question gets posed
about a Manhattan D.A who refuses to
enforce the law and all that my opponent
can come up with is talking about the
last election think about that
Congressman zeldon that exchange just
like several uh between Oz and fetterman
that exchange should be an insult to New
Yorkers she should be removed from
office just for that and with that my
little earpiece fell out but go ahead
I'm listening yeah New York doesn't have
recall elections so what we saw in San
Francisco can happen there but it can't
happen here but when they drafted the
New York state constitution they gave
the governor the authority to remove a
district attorney who refuses to enforce
the law and Alvin Bragg from day one has
refused to enforce the law I I've said
that he needs to be removed Kathy hokel
says he just got there cut him some
slack he's doing his job when Alvin
Bragg was throwing throwing Jose Alba
you remember the guy working in the
bodega who got attacked and he had to
defend himself Alvin Bragg threw Jose
Alba into Rikers Island slapped him with
a murder charge with an open Stab Wound
when I was in front of the District
Attorney's Office saying hey this guy
shouldn't be facing this murder charge
Kathy Holcomb asked about it and said
it's a local matter I'm not going to get
involved so this disconnect
I think Congressman what we have to say
tonight is New York it's time to save
yourselves you have a chance to save New
York amen the state I mean all of it
it's a great state it's no State left
behind and you did a fantastic job a lot
of people wouldn't
put themselves out there like you did
just to run for this position and
Congressman zeldon hats off to you
fantastic job tonight everybody
everybody has to go out and vote in two
weeks hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else